[Music]
and so today we're gonna talk about what
happens if and when intelligent life
contacts us so what would that be like
what should we say well we understand
what they're saying so to help us
discuss this our first guest is an
anthropologist at York University and
she researches amongst many other things
the evolution of intelligence the
colonization of space she's collaborated
with the NASA Astrobiology Institute the
SETI Institute and 100-year starship
program please welcome Katherine Denny
our next guest is an astronomer at
Columbia University where he leads the
cool world worlds lab he's at his
research team he's focused on
discovering new planets and moons please
welcome David King also joining us we
have a philosopher from Barnard College
which is at Columbia University she
specializes in the philosophy of
language and is the co-founder and
co-organizer of flip and annual
conference that brings together
philosophers and linguists from all over
the world please welcome Karen Lewis and
our final guest is a biophysicist and
head of the laboratory of integrative
neuroscience at Rockefeller University
among many things he studies the brains
and communication skills of dolphins
which is kind of like an alien species
so he's an expert in deciphering alien
languages
please welcome Marcelo Magnus go
let's say say David catches up to speed
on the ways in which science is
currently searching for intelligent life
sure so probably the most famous program
that's trying to look for evidence of
extraterrestrial civilizations is called
SETI SETI that's the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and
traditionally ever since Frank Drake
first started this project thing back in
the 1960s and with a famous project
called Project Ozma they started
listening for radio signals essentially
hoping that somebody was transmitting in
our direction and that makes a lot of
sense radio which is a form of
electromagnetic radiation travels at the
speed of light so it's the fastest form
of communication and it's very cheap to
produce and receive so it kind of makes
sense as a way to look more recently
scientists and I guess you might punch
me in with this group have been thinking
about other ways that you might be able
to reveal the presence of extra to
extraterrestrial civilizations one of
which might be that they are not
intending to tell us that they are here
they're not deliberately messaging us
but maybe we can still tell that they
are there by virtue of their technology
so maybe they're building some giant
alien engineering mega structure and we
might be able to see them in their act
of building that or maybe see the the
waste heat for instance from the giant
machines they're using so recently that
both of those approaches have emerged as
sort of the the main avenues we're using
and how do you see if someone's trying
to build this weird alien structure you
know yeah that's a good that's a good
question
it's almost like you know arthur c
clarke would say that as such an
advanced civilization would be
indistinguishable from magic in a way so
how on earth how on earth can you look
for something which could essentially be
magic and that's kind of what in a way
what we kind of do we look for things
which are unnatural so we think we
understand how stars work we think we
understand how planets are built around
planetary systems and we look for stuff
that is essentially just cannot be
explained by any of the means there's a
very famous type of signal that we look
for called a Dyson Sphere maybe some of
you have heard of that before
Freeman Dyson famously proposed that in
the 1960s and it's essentially saying
well you know if energy growth continues
at 2% per year which is about how energy
growth has been increasing over the last
few decades
eventually in like the year 3500 or
something if you extra
we would need the energy from the entire
Sun so how do you take the entire energy
of a star you build a shell around it so
we could maybe look for these giant
shells built around stars so you
wouldn't see the star light because it
been blocked out but you would see all
of the waste heat that they were
generating so they can't get around the
laws of thermodynamics hopefully
hopefully that's that's like if they can
beat thermodynamics then basically we
have no idea about how physics works at
all if they if they have to obey
thermodynamics and they should emit
still some waste heat energy and we look
for the heat signature of stars which do
not appear in visible light that appear
in the infrared and that would be a
giveaway that somebody is extracting all
of the light energy and doing something
with it so that's the type of signature
that we can look for any luck so far
no actually people have lit so it's been
about a hundred thousand nearby stars
which have been surveyed for Dyson
spheres and about a hundred thousand
galaxies which have been surveyed and so
far there's no conclusive evidence of
such a civilization which in a way is
kind of depressing it means that these
super advanced civilizations if they
exist they don't do that very often they
don't use entire stellar outputs of
stars yeah so if we're not just as a as
a species in terms of trying to find
alien life we're not just searching for
it actively we're also sending messages
we're broadcasting can you tell us a
little bit about that sure so there's a
program there's an institute called the
Metis Institute so messaging
extraterrestrial intelligence Institute
it's an outgrowth of a thread that was
kind of present in study from the
beginning which was the idea that well
one way to conduct the experiment
instead of just listening listening
listening go you who can see if anybody
answers so there's a pretty major
division I would say within the world of
SETI on that subject some people are
very firmly of the opinion that we
should just listen not broadcast others
say look if there's anything out there
to be worried about chances are it knows
we're here already so we may as well say
hello really quite different sets of
opinions on that and meditation where
you sit on this and it's quite
controversial but it is a go Dan like my
controversial and it's related to the
question of risk I should say so as an
anthropologist
rather than a person who is you know an
astronomer or somebody composing
messages to transmit I kind of study the
debates so I'm gonna be annoyingly
agnostic in this one as well and not
commit but so what I like to do instead
is can look at this question of well for
those who say that it in the public in
particular those who say that we should
transmit why are they saying not what
are their interests and what are their
concerns and for those who say we
shouldn't transmit what are their
reasons and then it all kind of spins
out into this larger question about okay
well we all share this planet together
how do we decide these things so it kind
of spins quickly and do a question of
public scientist relationships and
different camps on earth and all of that
so if we do say SETI does pick up a
signal maybe David what kind of signal
are we likely to get well that's a hard
question to answer it could be I mean
classically the signal that people have
been looking for is just a high-powered
narrow frequency narrowband Pass range
radio transmission that's all it is it's
just like a post that there's a this
star essentially appears very bright
when you look at the specific wavelength
of light which corresponds to radio
typically the frequencies they look at
is something called the waterhole that
is a frequency space in the universe
which is naturally very quiet so stars
produce radio waves quasars produce
radio waves galaxies emit plenty of
radio so you have to choose a frequency
where the universe is not noisy so this
is one particular bandpass called the
water hole that collectively SETI
scientists have been sort of honing in
on and if you saw a very high-powered
frequency that was way above the the
cosmic background noise then you would
say okay maybe there's something
interesting here but we've seen those
actually settle at home which is this
essentially the screensaver you can
download and it processes through data
that SETI have collected sees about 72
signals like that per day on average so
there are 72 high-powered frequencies
above the background noise and most of
them are just trash or interference so
this is just you know our own radio
transmitters bouncing off the atmosphere
coming back down or satellites and space
military satellites even and it's varied
to go through each one of those and
figure out is this genuinely something
alien or is this something just that was
interfering so you know one of the
dreams in it for a long time if SETI has
been what if you could put a radio
telescope on the back of the moon on the
far side of the Moon you wouldn't get
any of the radio interference from the
earth whatsoever so be a very very quiet
region and you just have the cosmos to
deal with and no human interference so
if we could build any kind of radio
telescopes do SETI that would surely be
the ready tasket we would want and then
maybe we'd have a much clearer review
for these things so say we did get a
signal that it wasn't terrestrial
interference Karen
would we be able to interpret it you're
the linguist okay well that's a great
question so I think there are a lot of
challenges in interpreting a signal so
first of all it's a matter of
recognizing the signal as communicative
in the first place right we don't want
to try I mean maybe there's other ways
to tell that it's evidence that there's
intelligent life out there right if it's
evidence that they have some sort of
technology that they couldn't have if
they weren't intelligent that that would
be sort of a non linguistic way of
communicating that there is intelligent
life but if you think okay there's a
signal and it's a piece of language and
they want to communicate something how
do we even figure out that something's
trying to be communicated in the first
place so if we think of what a language
is a language is a symbolic system first
of all meaning whenever you encode it
whether there's sort of sounds that are
coming into my mouth right now or
writing system or a signing system or
Braille or anything like that those are
just say the sounds are coming in my
mouth they're just sounds but they
encode certain meaning other sounds
don't encode meaning and some are very
complex and don't encode meeting for
example think of a song or something
like that music is made of notes but the
notes don't you know notes don't pick
out or refer to a particular thing in
the world so the first thing is just
recognizing that there's a symbolic
system here rather than something else
that occurs in nature something that's
not supposed to have meaning at all and
second of all the way language works
then what makes it linguistic is that
the speaker or the sender wanted to
communicate something with that message
and we have to figure out what they
wanted to communicate if it's just sort
of this random noise that came off into
the universe and we're trying to
interpret something that's on
so that's the first thing is just trying
to figure out whether this is something
we should be interpreting in the first
place the the next challenge is of
course if we think it is something we
should be interpreting it it's how to
decode that and I think there are
challenges at all sorts of levels one we
have to figure out just what the
individual so every language is made up
of building blocks of meaning so for
example if I just say something simple
like this chair is red and white
there's the words in the sentence or the
building blocks of meanings so we want
to figure out something like chair
refers to this sort of thing and then
there's the syntax the grammar how they
form together so when I say this chair
is red and white predicating the
properties being white and red of the
chair and we figure that out because we
know the grammar of English so whatever
communication we have if it's anything
linguistic it's gonna have these
building blocks of meaning and a way
that they they go together to
communicate a message and we're gonna
have to figure out both what those
building blocks refer to and then how
like we're having click together to make
a message and that's even further gonna
more gonna be complicated because
chances are the aliens have very
different things they want to talk about
than we do so they're not probably gonna
be talking about chairs and or
grandparents or people that bubble or
internet bubbles or anything like that
so even sort of searching for what these
building blocks could refer to it's
really hard because chances are it's
gonna be sort of outside of our concepts
and so even if somehow we decode that a
certain word refers to something we have
a hypothesis of what sort of thing or
first you we're not gonna have any sense
of sort of what does that what role does
that thing play in their society just as
if we sent messages about chairs even if
somehow they could figure out the word
chair or refer to like this sort of
thing I have no idea what what what a
chair is really or what role it plays in
our society so this is sort of even if
you can somehow and I doubt you can get
through all those first layers you're
gonna have at the end even if you
somehow decode the message in a certain
sense you're not really gonna understand
the message if I just add something to
that
you know in in terms of trying to
translate these messages it maybe it
maybe seems to us right now like it's a
long way off we'd be able to do that so
maybe the advanced civilization might
anticipate that and they might not
actually attempt to send necessarily a
specific message but just a broadcast
that they are in the first case just
intelligence so maybe you could just
send the prime number sequence so just a
series of you know like Morse code
almost like beep and just send the the
the series of prime numbers and then at
least we would know that that was not
there's no way that was a natural
process nothing in nature just spits out
prime numbers so you might not be able
to necessarily tell what how to build
some giant machine like in contact the
the 1907 film but you might at least be
able to say hey there's definitely
somebody smart there because that
shouldn't happen naturally and and David
so at the moment we're just kind of the
the fun world we live in is we get a
signal from far away how far away are we
talking here like what is what is the
closest that intelligent life could
currently be based on how much we've
scared yeah sure so we do I mean one of
the revolutions of the last 10 20 years
in astronomy has been the discovery of
all of these planets in a solar
neighborhood and beyond the galaxy is
about a hundred thousand light years
across to give you some sense of scale
and we have surveyed fairly fairly well
within about I'd say two thousand light
years of the Sun looking for planets and
we now know that most stars have
planetary systems around them and
something like ten percent of those
stars sun-like stars have also
earth-like planets around them so there
is no shortage of earth-like planets of
order of tens of billions likely in the
Milky Way galaxy alone the nearest
example is probably our nearest star
actually Proxima Centauri is the nearest
star you can't actually see it in the
sky because it's too faint it's a red
dwarf star much smaller than the Sun but
it is the nearest star it's just four
light-years away and we now know that
that has an earth-like planet around it
whether that planet truly is earth-like
though you know does it actually have a
habitable biosphere around it does it
have liquid water on it we don't know we
just know there's a planet there that is
essentially the same mass as the earth
and it has imprint support the right
distance from the star that it could
have liquid water okay so say that is
where intelligent life is me of four
light years away
so if they had sent us a signal how long
ago would they have sent that signal so
they mean if they're continuously bro
casting it then you know we would be
able to see it at any time we just look
up and we bill but when did they make it
it would be four years I mean if it's
four light years then radio just like
light travels at the speed of light so
it took four years for backwards
communication so every text message we
would send them there would be and you
know essentially we'd send it would take
four years to get there then for another
four years to come back so it'd be an
eight year turnaround time on on
communication for us to get a reply when
we send a message back so that makes it
very possible that we could have a
little nice back and forth but what
happens if intelligent life is thousands
of years away thousands of light years
away yeah that'sthat's Mengers hard and
this is where Metis you know the the
messaging aspect is somewhat limited
because we've only been producing radio
waves for what a hundred years would you
say something like this so only a
hundred light year bubble around the
earth actually would be aware of our
radio transmissions everybody else in
the Milky Way up to a hundred thousand
light years away they might be able to
tell there's a habitable planet here but
they wouldn't know that we were
producing radio waves because there
hasn't been enough time for those really
weights to reach them yet so yes
certainly when you look at the grander
scale of the Milky Way it's a very
limited volume of the Milky Way that
would certainly know that we were
producing radio emissions so Kathryn
tell us if we if we did get a signal
that was from a planet thousands of
light-years away how do we know that
civilization is still existing we don't
so I mean that's one of the really
difficult things so let's assume a
signal does come in and I think
everything that you've said in terms of
the content is that are is super
important and there are also facets of
the way that search is conducted that
means that a signal would be somewhat
averaged out and so a lot of the content
would simply drop out so first of all I
think it's important to realize that
content if it is there would be
difficult to decipher and so anything
that would conceivably tell us kind of
the status of that civilization we just
really actually wouldn't have access to
so let's say that we do get a signal
it's only one as a I mean observations
would of course continue to see if there
was a steady stream or something like
that but let's say that a signal comes
in we would really have a difficult time
I think deciding whether that
civilization
or that society let's use that word
instead perhaps is extant or extinct and
then that kind of changes the equation
in some ways there's been a couple of
great science-fiction stories for
example about transmissions from an
alien society but basically they're just
transmitting to say goodbye we're dying
oh no how does that make us feel better
I don't know anyway that we can study
societies on earth to know like does
society have the lifespan and then we
just build nuclear weapons and
eventually kill ourselves right okay
great question when Carl Sagan was
writing about the lifetimes of
technological civilizations he was very
concerned about our own so for example
when cosmos came out in 1980 he was kind
of fighting a battle on the side at the
same time a really really important one
regarding the effects of nuclear winter
and the fact that a nuclear war isn't
winnable so he was very preoccupied at
that time with this idea of our
technological adolescence you know how
do we as a global society deal with the
fact that we've achieved the capacity to
a destroy ourselves and he was hoping
that if we find a signal from the great
beyond that it would be proof that
another civilization has survived this
technological adolescence and has kind
of come out the other side and that
maybe they could teach us something
about how to be a sustainable ideally a
peaceful civilization but the thing is
you know if we're trying to understand
civilizations out there from
civilizations here it's personally my
opinion as an anthropologist is that
well we can speculate all we like but it
is speculation you're here to do but I
actually I don't think that we can say
anything all that meaningful so there's
kind of been every Theory put forward
about okay well for a civilization to
last a long time they would have to be
peaceful others saying no they would
just have to be hyper aggressive and
wipe everybody out the problem is it's
that we don't have the data to
distinguish between those possibilities
at this time and so if we do if a
detection is achieved we won't actually
know for sure what that means and you
kind of every conceivable specialty
unearthing well this means this or isn't
this means this but we won't actually
know so then that comes into these
questions about well what do you want to
believe and how much do you want to
believe it that kind of is a nice
leading to take this let's take this
alien adventure into Phase two so say we
don't just get a signal but the alien
spaceship arrives yeah and they come out
we're gonna then also ship this
conversation into a couple of years but
my cell it let's spend some time talking
about your research you essentially talk
to an alien species if you will dolphin
so after decades of research because
when these aliens come we're gonna want
to communicate with them after decades
of research how well can we communicate
with dolphins well they would say not
terribly well at all we in my particular
case I started studying dolphins five
years ago thinking that it it would be
shown that we would be able to have an
understanding of at least whether or not
they have something a communication
system approaching the complexity of
human language and five years later I
can tell you that I will still have an
idea it's it's remarkably difficult to
understand all of these issues the
moment you step away from
anthropomorphism right I mean it's very
easy to imagine that you can communicate
with the great apes with which we have
so much in common but the moment you
step into completely different physical
environments like water ok and you're
trying to communicate with these with
these other animals okay there are some
extent to which we understand each other
as mammals all do with one another and
some extent to which we don't can you
tell me perhaps an example of where
maybe you had your your best
communication with the dolphin after
five years where you really felt
yeah we're getting somewhere here my
best communication my best communication
okay so my best communication was once
we were diving we were pursuing a group
we we had
group of teenage dolphins off of Belize
and they were just lounging around and
you know horsing with one another some
of some of them were sort of sleeping a
siesta it was 2 p.m. and they were all
teenagers if I recall correctly they
were all male and they were just
coursing with each other teenage style
okay they were raking their teeth on
each other and stuff and there was a
group of these two teenage dolphins that
were going like that kinton seneschal
group of teenagers at the cafeteria that
are always together going around and
sneaking at everybody else and we have
been following them with with the
helicopter drones okay and at some point
batteries conked out and I decide okay
I'm gonna jump in the water with a GoPro
and record from the water because we had
been on them for like an hour half okay
and it was really fascinating you know
this display of behavior and I get in
the water and there's these two
teenagers that come around and dolphins
always when you're in the water you hear
them well before you can see them so so
the sounds that dolphins make a
combination of two very different sounds
one of them is a whistle like at very
high frequencies they sound like and a
different sound is made by their
echolocation clicks that sounds like and
they can post that at extremely fast
pace okay and when they do that it
sounds like a creaking door maybe like
this chair that's creaking a lack of
thing and so these these two guys okay
were just lounging around okay they come
around they look at me they echolocate
on me they turn and the moment they turn
is the chattering and I had the most
distinct impression they were laughing
it that's the one time I understood what
they were I don't know exactly what they
were saying about me okay
maybe they maybe they didn't like my
fins maybe they thought that my figure
in the in the water wasn't shapely okay
or that or maybe they were commenting on
the fact that having both sides on the
front of the face instead of the sides
makes me look like a flounder or
something I don't know okay but we have
two videos this is one of dolphins I
think Johnny introducing a yes I think
that the video so here we are on a boat
okay you can see we have to go through
balls and you heard the sounds of the
dog is just before they came about
riding onto the front of the boat okay
so what you're seeing is a film made
from the front of the boat dolphins from
you know we know from the time of the
Greek that they loved about ride
they loved to surf on the pressure wave
in the front of the in the front of the
boat and this is one of the things we're
trying to study we're trying to get them
to catch their communication in a very
restricted activity so that by
restricting the nature of the activity
we can correlate what we are doing with
our weather emissions and we have a
better chance that because otherwise
language is combinatorial and there's no
way you can explore all possible
combinations of all possible things okay
that you're never going to be able to
fill up a table with all the
combinations okay just by observing so
what we do in this case is we try to
restrict the kind of behavior so that
presumably there is a restricted set of
words or verbs or you know whatever is
it that they use okay say like hey let's
go to the shore yes oh so if they are
doing acrobatics okay and there's a
systematic we select those like every
time that one is gonna empower the other
one we have it you know we have at least
proof that there's a correlation between
a given vocal emission and a given
physical act okay we don't believe you
know being next to the dolphins we don't
believe that that's any way that we can
actually figure out the language if we
cannot correlate the behavior that's why
I don't think that you would learn a
language an alien language just by
listening to a transmission okay because
I mean you would have to find the
recursive means of defining how to
transmit the dictionary okay and what I
mean by these and how do you refer to
physical objects okay if you don't have
a common frame okay so you talked about
this a little bit but what does your
knowledge about how dolphins how much we
now understand about how dolphins speak
how much confidence does that give you
that will understand what the aliens
tell us well I mean we live with
dolphins we have known dolphins for
2,000 years okay you know I mean we are
I mean go to the to the Metropolitan
Museum you'll see them all of all over
the Greek wing you'll see you know they
were sacred animals in in Greece so I
know it doesn't give me great confidence
if the moment that you step away from
you know from certain commonalities I
mean the interesting thing is that
dolphins are still mammals recognizably
mammals and they have a certain they are
able to recognize gestures and interact
with us in ways that I would not
anticipate necessarily would be the case
with an alien species who might not even
be made out of carbon I don't mean they
might be some gas cloud so who knows
what what they are okay I mean but you
know I mean the moment you pause it you
know people with you know with limbs and
stuff okay already positing a lot right
and you know it's interesting dolphins
do not have arms yet when you know
trainers pointed something dolphins
understand they're pointing and
something and they are into that okay so
even though they don't even though they
don't have means of pointing with with
hands so there's all these commonalities
that come from having a common neural
substrate we have brains of an
essentially similar architecture okay
our whatever our engines in her brain
that parse motion that parse attitudes
okay the
they come from a common ground okay and
therefore when we interact together we
understand gestures dolphins are very
gestural okay they you know there's a
lot of non vocal communication between
them in addition to the vocal
communication which is a lot so I don't
know I mean if you if you work together
with an alien with which you cannot even
understand physical gestures okay where
do you start
I have no idea this takes us what a
beautiful segue to the linguist where do
we start
if you our era our Amy Adams said to the
aliens and they say Karen just just sort
it out what are they you know what are
the steps walk me through what would you
do what that was like I mean I don't
know how much feet we could do so I mean
it in one sense the stuff Marcela
brought up is very relevant because so
now in this scenario I'm faced with the
alien so I can get a little bit of sense
of what it I do they resemble something
like a mammal so in one sense
chances are the aliens share no kind of
similarity to our brain architecture to
our neural architecture so I can't
assume that they have the way they
process the world is the same as the way
I process the world or the way dolphin
processes the world but I could at least
maybe see if they have something that
looks kind of like arms or legs or sense
whether they have vision so the first
thing I think I would do and I should
say I'm not a field linguist so I don't
not like Amy Adams and the movies a
field linguist I think and she goes out
into the field these are people who
actually go out and talk to people and
try to figure out how foreign languages
work but I think the one thing I would
do and one thing that I don't think is
highlighted very often it's just figure
out what their physical senses are like
can they see do they see things and
roughly the same way do i process vision
and roughly the same way we do can they
hear at what frequency can they hear
what kind of sounds or gestures or other
signals are they emitting to get a sense
for what kind of modality I'm even going
to try to communicate with them so in to
go back to arrival amy adams decides to
start writing in english which is not i
think how I would start by writing on a
write of white
in English because that might be one of
the hardest ways for them to figure out
what I was saying to them and I think at
some point I she she goes I don't know
if I'm remembering this right but she's
tries to teach them one of the first
things it something like her name and
that she's walking which is a really
weird thing to start with
maybe not the name but you have to
assume that they have a practice of
naming too and they're gonna understand
what you're doing and then these animals
don't walk at all that she's dealing
with in their movie they're kind of
cephalopods that move through this weird
kind of substance like this and so they
kind of walk if I kind of like shuffle
shuffle so I'm not sure so the this is
just a highlight that it's not clear
what kind of concepts that would have so
it's not clear where you can start but I
think starting by seeing how they
respond to the environment just taking
data on sort of what sounds or images or
other kind of data they admit under
what's or certain stimuli would be there
can you give me an example um can I give
you an example uh yeah sure
so I mean just very simply the idea
would be suppose like I take an object
like um I have like a red square and I
put it in front of them and then I see
if they say anything or if they pick it
up what did I say and then I can maybe
vary that like try a red ball and then
if something is in common I mean this is
a very Toya example because it would
take a lot more data than this but they
say something in common maybe they're
picking up on red and then pick it
something else it's the same shape as
the cube but a different color and if
there's something in common with what
they admitted with the first thing then
maybe they were talking about the shape
so maybe this gives me some indication
of what their language is like and some
indication are they picking up on color
or shape or something like that tell me
about this idea that David suggested
with using maths prime numbers was the
example what do you think about this
idea of what if we just started you know
yeah so I think there's there's two
things to think about with using math so
some people talk about so his idea of
using just a sequence of prime numbers I
think for that the question is sort of
what do you want to do in communicating
now if you want to just indicate that
there's intelligent life here then I
think that might be a good way to go
right because if it's true that prime
numbers don't occur
in nature you might be showing well
here's some sort of signal that was
something non natural here something
that has to be produced by an
intelligent species but I'm gonna be
particularly impressed on ya humans yeah
but if you wanted to do more than just
say hey we're here if you want to
communicate then you might have to go
beyond matha beyond at least simple
sequences of things like time numbers
the second thing I think to keep in mind
as some people talk about math is this
universal language but math itself is
not a language when we're talking about
mathematical concepts they still have to
be encoded in some sort of symbolic
system that is they're still going to be
these units of meaning that are somewhat
arbitrary that match onto the concepts
it'll be completely arbitrary like in a
sense of representing numbers we can do
one beat for one two beeps for two or
something like that but once you get
beyond the numbers if you want to encode
addition let's say you know we encoded
in our mathematical system by writing a
little plus but that's just one of the
many ways we could arbitrarily encode
addition or something like that
and they're still gonna have to decode
it or if they send a message to us about
math we're still gonna have to decode it
and they're still gonna be a syntax
there's you know in way our writing
system for math if we want to write two
plus two is four first with the two then
we put the plus in the middle then we
put the two equals and four but there's
systems like an computer programming
languages where you might put the plus
up front all right that's just a very
simple system and so there's still a
syntax there still a grammar to math and
they're still in encoding and someone's
still gonna have to figure that out
so I think it solves some of the
challenges because I think there is good
reason to think that any especially if
the aliens have arrived on earth that
they have enough understanding of
mathematics to have filled the spaceship
and come here and so we saw some of the
systems because maybe that's the one
place where we share some concepts we
can solve some of the problems rather
because that's one place where we share
some concepts but we haven't solved sort
of many of the layers if I could just
add a little bit it actually touches on
the messy as well the the messaging
because when the first messages were
being designed and Carl Sagan helped
design some of the messages one example
is the Arecibo message that was very
famously broadcast from the inn in
Puerto Rico this giant Arecibo ray and
another was a
these gold discs and carvings that were
put on the Voyager spacecraft that Carl
Sagan also had a hand in putting on and
on them there is some a little bit of
maths and they they're often designed to
try to teach you the syntax so give
several examples of two to four and it
doesn't remember the simple stuff they
see enough for example which hopefully
they can figure out what's what the
syntax is and then also just diagrams
this is what a human being looks like
this is the local pulsars around us so
you can locate exactly where the where
the earth is for instance that was on
these original messages the downside of
that is though with a gold disk it's
kind of you just hold it and you can
kind of just look at it and it's not
there's no way to decode it you're just
sort of really studying the content the
Arecibo message was at 23 by 73 pixel
image but if you if I didn't know it was
that way around if they did 73 by 23
instead you just get garbage so you have
to know the key to like construct the
image so a visual representation seems
appealing because you could teach them
all of maths and what a human being
looks like but if they don't know the
correct key they might unlock and it
looks like garbage to us and they're
like oh that's that looks like something
I recognise and they might think that's
the correct signal but if they don't
know in advance what the key is then
they're kind of stuck me me add that I
think that it's a huge assumption to
think that the aliens think that one
plus one is the beginning of math okay
that we are based on we're beings at the
something less scale energy scale we
have fingers we can turn our fingers we
start with counting okay if you have an
intelligence who operated in the quantum
mechanical regime quantum computing is
from the mentally distinct from
arithmetic computing you know and they
might not have object you know the
notion of objects as you know the
counting objects as the primary method
of method of counting so it might not be
it might not be that an alien
civilization considers one two three
five seven
you know the 11 to be a proof of
intelligence okay okay I mean so even
even at this level if if you do not put
a bound
on which kind of you know life you're
dealing with okay then you cannot
conceivably put it down on how you're
gonna communicate with them I think
you're right
in a way you kind of have no choice but
to put a bound because otherwise we
sufficiently similar to us so when you
take a baby and you put them in any
culture they can learn the language so
should we just give the aliens a baby
and then wait for it to grow up could we
just make a baby live amongst the
Dolphins and then could we then get it
to decipher so if we were to discover
and contact intelligent life it would be
you know one of the biggest moments of
human history if not the biggest how do
you think it would go over on earth
Kathryn I mean what does have an X it
depends as an anthropologist that's the
only answer I can give so it depends on
what's happening in the world at that
time it depends on who who you all right
now say right now tomorrow tomorrow what
time 980 early 930 yeah
commute everyone's can it coming today
okay all right how does how is how does
the detection unfold to wait on Twitter
okay Twitter we go 9:30
who's it coming from the aliens I was
coming straight from the aliens that's
awesome
okay now this we can have fun with okay
so the aliens have hacked Twitter say it
comes from the city Twitter account okay
he's saying it's coming from one of the
study Twitter accounts okay found it hi
yeah
little alien M ID so I think you know
here's the really interesting thing then
it I think we're gonna have a whole lot
of human questions at that moment right
so like maybe in the QA we can talk
about what your questions would be at
that moment like what would you want to
know and I think um you know so there
are a lot of really important things
that would affect the reception of that
signal first of all so let's imagine
let's imagine you're in North Korea and
you've just heard this news from the US
what's your reaction other places in the
world similarly I mean so would they
accept say the authority of of a
scientist coming out of the u.s. about
you know we really didn't find this
thing given all the atmosphere around
fake news and all that I think there
could be a lot of distrust a lot of
confusion and a lot of uncertainty about
who - could it trust let's say I should
specify here I'm Canadian so let's say
that the President of the United States
decides to get in on the Twitter team so
what I know I know it's really unheard
of but like what happens then so does
that contribute or detract or you know
it certainly messes things up creatively
and interesting then you know there's
the effects on the stock market so
people are kind of going okay what do we
want to invest in what do we want to
divest from okay
weapons pharmaceuticals prepping
equipment yeah you can kind of easily
imagine things like that
from the surveys that have been done on
people's anticipation about
extraterrestrial life etc some people
are very anxious about it some people
are very excited some people are like
beam me up please others are like no no
no I'm heading for the hills so there
could be a lot of different responses
and I think when I said you know it
depends it depends also on what else is
happening in the world so if you're in a
war zone already if you're recently
recovering from a war if you've been
traumatized in any way this might really
be the last thing that you want if on
the other hand you're just kind of very
hopeful about what aliens might provide
it's a human civilization you know so
and there's also from the surveys that
have been done there's a real kind of
difference in degree of likelihood to
believe so there are regional
differences there are political
differences so who is more likely to
believe well so and there's also
questions about me know governmental
authority and help
people are more likely to believe in
conspiracies etc so I mean there's
differences between the West the Midwest
the Northeast
there's male/female wait so if there was
a sign who isn't like other West so is
like Californians versus New York like
well I don't have the statistics right
in my head cuz I was like the one that
did the research is that I think the
point I'm just trying to make is that
there is variation and then that's going
to affect kind of the overall reception
and then there's the question of oh my
goodness well what do we do because
again some people are very much in favor
of sending a reply and whether or not
there's a global response that says yes
let's write a message us together and
send it you know somebody's going to you
know it's it's just gonna happen and
then other people will be upset because
it'll be like I wish you'd just stayed
quiet and I think there you know there
could be until you know scope for quite
a lot of friction here so the research
that has been done on potential
receptions to contact it indicates a lot
of instability so I think one frame that
study is understood within is just the
idea that this would just be a
continuation of all the research that
has indicated that while we're not the
center of the universe so you know we
are just on a planet orbiting a Sun you
know many planets orbiting many Suns so
that's been the huge contribution of
astronomy over the last few centuries
it's been kind of decentering us right
so that's one frame of understanding but
another is that okay well these are
others sentient beings it's not just
about our place so then it all becomes
about well what's that relationship
going to be like and how does that play
into existing relationships here on
earth so micellar as someone who doesn't
research this this specific question
directly I mean as a as a regular
civilian but rational thinker what how
would you feel yeah well first of all
the the most important thing is to know
what kind of signal we got namely if we
got a signal from 2,000 light-years away
okay and these guys might not be even be
alive right now it's very different than
if you have a huge UFO you know right
over Central Park okay yeah so it's
it obviously is a very different thing
in every single science fiction movie in
which you have a arrival of a hostile
civilization their UFOs are creepy and
whenever a friendly civilization comes
okay the UFOs are are cute and you know
and and this is absurd okay namely that
is that there is no basis for thinking
that we have a common aesthetic code or
that they would make any you know
devices for transport okay according to
our preferences Israel
what is creepy or cute right so all of a
sudden comes this huge enormous Li you
know creepy you know UFO and the guy
says hey right we even okay I mean
there's this you know it's really making
all this thing up there is actually
almost a dress rehearsal of exactly what
happened they yeah really a real example
of this which was the War of the Worlds
broadcast in 1938 so that was a radio
broadcast by columbia broadcasting
systems and it's in it's HG Wells's
famous story that was radio made for
radio and with an with the narrator and
it's it's done in a way that's like a
news report if you listen to it so
people who just tuned in halfway through
really thought it was an invasion
because it sounds like journalists on
the scene during you know the moments
when the aliens come out of the
spaceship and stuff and start lasering
everyone so people were pretty panicked
about it and actually the the telephone
switchboard at the broadcaster got
completely unindicted with phone cause
of concern people police have arrived
the radio station and then there was a
journalist it reports the next day at
the New York Times had a headline about
you know people confused thinking the
radio broadcast was real so that was
kind of like one of the few insights
other that was not that wasn't really
contact that was a hostile invasion
so that was it's not surprising people
panicked in that case but it does it's
one of the few historical instances
where we have some insight as to how
people might react thinking it was a
genuine event that's an interesting one
too because it kind of spun out into
this whole new kind of distrust in the
popular
Media because the feeling was well if
you could pull that on us you know
that's not cool and so it actually
started an interesting trend but there
has also been a lot of reanalysis of
that one about you know just exactly how
much people were panicked etc but there
have also been echoes so there was a
case for example a few years later in
Quito where the same thing was
rebroadcast unfortunately it went really
really badly in that particular case and
it was because they've only recently
come out of a war themselves horrific
invasions etc and the people who had
fought defensively in that war didn't
think this was funny they torched the
radio station people died you know and
that one doesn't get cited but that's
something that I think of for example
when I kind of think about you know
potential negative consequences and just
a question for everyone on the panel
what do you think of this idea that if
we know there's alien life out there
we'll all forget our differences and
like save racism for the aliens that's
the usual kind of hopeful take on things
it's part of the kind of this Sagan ask
justification for shifting our frame of
reference and for and what I want I say
justification that sounds a little bit a
little bit harsh it's the it's the kind
of the cultural frame of reference that
says by you know having that
confirmation that you know again another
Society has survived their technological
adolescence that you know it could bring
out the best in us somehow from what I
understand of world history I don't
really buy it I think it has just as
much potential to bring out divisions
especially if there is actually some
degree of actual contact I don't think
it would be surprising to see jockeying
because this is something we've seen in
real contact episodes on earth it's not
just you know one side and the other
side it's like how can I make this work
to my advantage and so it's people
trying to build alliances and then it
becomes my enemy's enemy is my friend it
gets very complicated it doesn't just
kind of come down into you know oh we're
all suddenly you know unified as in
humanity you know holding hands singing
Kumbaya etc I think it's likely to be
more complicated than that and not
necessarily also adorable and I agree I
think it's it's very also just very
unlikely that even in the presence
a new other that's perhaps way more
other than any of the ones we have on
earth like the alien being the new other
that were not I'm likely we're gonna
overcome you know thousands of years of
racism and xenophobia and notice our
commonalities in those moments rather
than perhaps those differences being
highlighted by the fact that we now have
to deal with some sort of imminent
potentially harmful event maybe I mean
this is really highly speculative
maybe over if the aliens remained
interacting with people of Earth over a
long long period of time they would be
so different that there would be more
alliances between earth people and they
would be the new other but I don't think
that would be anything like an instant
reaction and I don't even think that
would necessarily be a likely thing to
happen over a long period of time Damon
well I I just often say to my class that
you could travel for a billion
light-years in any direction in the
universe and you will not meet another
human being that every human being on
this planet is extremely rare and
precious in the context of the entire
universe even though it seems like
there's a lot of us there's like you
know maybe a billion or 7 billion people
right now in the planet if you divide
that by the size this universe is very
very few of us so I think isn't it just
even forgetting aliens exist or not if
you just take a cosmic perspective that
you would maybe think of your fellow
human being as being a bit more worthy
of your kindness and compassion than if
you if you just had this versus their
Matta - how's it going to react when the
aliens come so I think it's almost it's
the better approach is just to think
about the vast vast scale of the
universe rather than to worry about
interspecies relations so if we if we
haven't had that feeling of warmth
already right so basically everybody
goes oh when they look at dolphins so
maybe maybe there's hope for aliens
unifying us but of course it depends in
which guys they can right I mean if
they're hostiles okay this
immediately an exacerbation of all your
divisions so-and-so is collaborating
with them okay or they are gonna you
know there's gonna be three soon or
these or that and that's when I being
flamed you know not in flat right
so I David I mean in the popular
imagination and even in sort of
scientific thinking now there's the
pendulum has sort of switched just with
the numbers game but there is probably
intelligent life out there somewhere
whether we would ever communicate with
it we don't know but like it seems like
the scientific pendulum has switched
it's probably out there what if what if
it is not out there like what what if we
are alone you know how does that change
your thinking yeah so I just first say
that I personally challenge challenge
the idea that the numbers game proves
that therefore those intelligence
everywhere I mean this is kind of a very
beginning of the show but there's
there's no reason why the probability
can be very very tiny people often cite
the fact that life emerged early on the
earth as proof of the fact that
therefore life must start very easily
but it took four billion years of
evolution to get to this point in a
billion years the Sun will make the
earth uninhabitable so they kind of had
to have started pretty soon else we
wouldn't be here to observe it so it's a
bit of a circular argument so you really
can't take the early start to the life
on earth as meaning anything so to
answer your question more directly if if
it does indeed turn out that life is
incredibly precious then I guess that
just really reinforces my original point
about how precious human beings are on
this earth that there is obviously a set
of circumstances which happened here in
the solar system which makes it
extremely special in a cosmic
perspective I would still be pretty
skeptical that forever throughout the
entire history of the universe there
will be no life elsewhere in the
universe I'd I leave intelligence aside
and just say life elsewhere and the
reason is because in 10 trillion years
there will still be some stars which are
burning hydrogen and still will have
planets around them in in the right
distance for life in ten trillion years
and the universe is only about ten
billion years old
so we're at the very beginning of the
story of the universe still and actually
most most stars are these small M Dwarfs
which will still be burning into the far
distant future so I think maybe we're
just if we happen to be alone right now
it probably means we're just one of the
first rather than we're necessarily
going to be the only ones that will ever
ever exist I'd probably take that
perspective a little bit more I think
the idea that the fact we're alone right
now proves that's it that's it we're
done we're the only ones that will ever
be I wouldn't quite buy that argument so
there's plenty of time left in age of
the universe for other things to happen
and we're gonna open it up to everyone
in the audience now if you have
questions just hold out until we have a
microphone on your mouth with respect to
David's point about being early do we
think maybe AI could help us find them
better than humans yeah sure I think
certainly machine learning techniques of
which you know artificial intelligence
is sort of an extension of that are
already being used to help the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence so
this algorithm that you can download in
your computer called SETI at home
actually basically does that it
essentially uses some machine learning
algorithms to scan through these huge
libraries of data which have been
collected or the radio transmissions and
see if there's anything that looks like
a significant pattern amongst that data
and those algorithms are improving all
the time and as we get closer and closer
towards these very sophisticated AIS I
have no doubt that it would greatly help
us sift through as if through more and
more data so yeah I think you're exactly
right that as the as our software more
generally improves we can expect to be
able to do a more complete job of
surveying the sky for advanced
civilizations so you tossed out this
idea in a haphazard way of giving a baby
to an alien and I'm actually curious if
there might be a sort of more realistic
implementation of using the natural
resources that we have in our own
children to bridge languages with
dolphins or aliens or other human
civilizations is that something that's
been done or that could actually be you
know labor laws notwithstanding
I guess I can take that one so there has
been a large number of what's called
cross-fostering experiments van and I'm
know were familiar with all of that
literature but what typically happens is
that unless you're actually giving a
human child to another human okay and
let's remember that the real are
genetically speaking no races okay so
that it's it's just a member of the same
species okay that's not cross-fostering
okay but for instance if you raise a
canary among zebra finches the canary
will try to learn to sing like a silver
finch that has a very different song and
at some level it will acquire many of
the elements of the song and it will
fail to Coit others because at some at
some level you know there's a breakdown
in how much their hard work can imitate
you know canary sing something that if
you slow it down is sort of like the
korean chant well zebra finches are
rappers
and there's simply no way in which a
canary can sing zebra finch song they
just are ill-equipped
okay so cross-fostering experiments
really run a fall-off you know
differences in hardware that are in
tramonto right like in this particular
case okay you can't have a human baby
breathing underwater you cannot leave it
to those things okay I mean it's part of
the Hemings part of the sheikah hood of
the joke right but you really cannot
there's there's a limitation to how much
you can cross foster okay across species
that are actually physically distinct so
dolphins for instance they communicate
in a ultrasound range okay some of which
we can hear most of which we cannot they
see in a visual range okay that they
don't see red they don't see orange this
their vision starts in the in the green
okay and it goes all the way to to
violet and maybe beyond
and therefore they see naturally in a
different spectral range just like they
speak and hearing different spectral
range there's nothing in nate in a human
baby that if a human baby is raised with
the species that speaks at the different
frequency range they wouldn't be able to
hear that disaster ill-equipped in the
same way that we will never no matter
who raises as we will never see
ultraviolet or infrared it's just the
way our senses are encoded so there's
there's there's intrinsic limitations of
how much you can do this and because the
physical environment determines so much
how we perceive the world
okay our senses are exquisitely adjusted
okay to our sensory environment okay
and to our evolutionary history so I
don't think there's any way to actually
do anything else I just I'm gonna jump
in on that and say this another another
limitation on this kind of thing is that
a lot of linguists think that humans
have something called universal grammar
which is something like and something to
do with like an innate language faculty
they're common even though languages can
be very different all human languages
have some commonalities in their grammar
and in the Census some some part of us
some part of the hardwiring of our brain
that were the kind of creatures they're
just born knowing how to pick up human
languages and then we're immersed in a
particular language and that's why you
know babies can learn whatever language
that they're born into but there's no
real reason to think that an alien
language maybe dolphin language because
at least we have some commonality I
don't I'm not gonna speak on dolphins
but there's no reason to think that an
alien language is gonna share that
universal grammar so even if we could
take one of our human babies all the
other concerns notwithstanding and send
them to live with the aliens it's not
clear that we have the right kind of a
human baby would have the right kind of
brain to even pick up the alien language
yes I was just gonna say following on I
think one of the things the children
have and are encouraged in his curiosity
and I think that's the first place in
any kind of communication challenge
starts and the reason I'm just thinking
about this is because of laboratory mice
so one of the most studied creatures on
the planet right and it took decades for
somebody to notice that they sing I know
right so Google white my singing it's
gonna be really interesting and but you
know it's because of course they're
outside of our frequency range so nobody
could hear them and nobody noticed that
when the mice are doing this it's like
and they have little mouths and then
they're singing so but it took somebody
kind of looking differently too and and
you know miking them and then putting it
through a computer to realize oh my
goodness and now of course there's this
lovely study on you know what are my
singing and when are they singing to
each other and what does it all mean but
it took that kind of spark that moment
of curiosity and I think you know that's
something that we can all kind of
encourage in ourselves as we you know
address are many different communication
challenges salience or not and with that
we've run out of time um thank you very
much thanks everyone and please think
again
[Applause]
[Music]